steve rogers the world war ii hero and
perennial avenger known as captain
america
has been a cultural icon since he was
famously introduced
punching adolf hitler in the face on the
cover of captain america comics number
one
well you might already know about his
decades spent as an icicle or his
frenemy relationship with iron man
there's plenty of lesser-known details
about the sentinel of liberty
here is the untold truth of captain
america
before we get started does anyone want
to get out
he trains every avenger captain america
is among the finest hand-to-hand
combatants in the marvel universe
thanks to his vast experience training
and enhanced strength and reflexes
as such he trains just about every hero
who has come through the avengers
revolving door
among his more interesting students the
invincible iron man
she hulk hawkeye and even mary jane
watson
maybe he should be called drill sergeant
america your fighting style is to tackle
people or blast them
if i had to guess i'd say that you've
never been in an actual fight in your
life
multiple buckies almost as well known as
cap himself is his original sidekick
bucky barnes
barnes was a mascot at the military base
where rogers was stationed in the early
days of world war ii
who was taken under the captain's wings
bucky was presumed
dead along with cap in the fateful plane
crash that led to cap's hibernation
although the young sidekick would return
decades later as the winter soldier
lucky who the hell is bucky rogers would
eventually pick up another young
sidekick in the modern era
rick jones rick jones was directly
involved in the accident which
created the hulk and it was his distress
call which initially caused the avengers
to form
having been taken in by the team as an
honorary member
jones answered the call when cap found
himself in need of another partner
undergoing combat training and even for
a time wearing bucky's old uniform
the partnership didn't last long but
rick jones would continue to be a
sidekick for just about everyone in the
marvel universe
replaced by black panther in avengers
number 47
cap decides to take a leave of absence
from the team to set off on his own
adventures
a journey that would bring him to
wakanda where he would encounter perhaps
his only viable replacement
in black panther tell me captain america
is it really your shield after helping
cap to foil a plot by baron zemo to
destroy the united states using advanced
weaponry
t'challa accompanies cap back to america
mulling over his suggestion to join the
avengers as cap's replacement
t'challa quickly proves his worth in a
fight against the grim reaper and the
grateful team makes t'challa a
full-fledged member
after that cap would only make cameo
appearances in avengers comics until
returning to the team a full 3 years
later
the falcon and the red skull sam wilson
the falcon has been cap's staunchest
friend and ally
over the years their formal partnership
began way back in 1971's captain america
number 133
but strangely their long association
never would have happened if not for one
of the red skull's many evil plots to
kill captain america
in captain america number 117 steve
rogers is banished to a mysterious
island after getting his body switched
with the red skull
while there cap disguises himself as a
normal guy and runs into sam wilson a
harlem bird enthusiast who trains with
cap to become the falcon
together the two of them foil the red
skull's plot cap gets his body back and
sam wilson
embarks on a long crime fighting career
as the falcon
captain america and the captain americas
steve rogers might be the most famous
captain america but he's far from the
only one
after becoming disillusioned with
america and donning the new identity of
nomad
steve rogers left the captain america
identity available
and a trio of schmoes tried out for the
job while the first two bailed after
realizing just how perilous the job was
roscoe simmons received training from
the falcon himself
unfortunately he met a gruesome end at
the hands of the red skull
forcing rogers to return as captain
america to end the school's murderous
wrath
later wracked by fear of compromising
his principles he surrendered the
official captain america role to john
walker the super patriot
in favor of operating independently as
the captain
walker even kept cap's shield during
this time while rogers used a replica
john walker would later become u.s agent
once steve rogers returned to reclaim
the shield and trademark identity
in addition both bucky barnes and sam
wilson have likewise taken over the
mantle but rogers has always found his
way back from death
retirement or even just comic book limbo
you just don't know when to give up do
you do this all day
will the real cap please stand up in
2016
marvel used the relaunch title captain
america steve rogers to introduce the
most insanely controversial plot twist
in a history full of them
at the issue's end cap suddenly murders
his sidekick jack
flagg before uttering two words which
had cab fans the world over
reeling in shock hail hydra
it turned out that rogers had been
reconstructed by a sentient version of
the cosmic
cube after a near-death experience
unfortunately
the red skull had indoctrinated the cube
in one of the many times that he had
wielded it
causing roger's entire history to be
retconned as a hydra secret agent
as you might expect the real captain
america managed to escape his
imprisonment inside the cube's memory
and promptly defeated his fascist
counterpart
what makes the
chose to shield his shield must heal
cap's shield is perhaps the most iconic
tool in any superhero's arsenal
not only is it virtually indestructible
it can absorb vast amounts of kinetic
energy which is why it can withstand
blows from the hulk or thor without
simply sending cap flying
in its original comic incarnation the
shield isn't pure vibranium but an
alloy accidentally created by scientist
myron mclean
in a metallurgical accident mclean was
tasked by the us government with the
creation of a super strong metal to be
used in tanks
and one night while laboring over the
project mclean fell asleep
he awoke to find that the materials he'd
been working with had mysteriously
bonded
and cast the new substance using a disc
shaped mold for tank hatches
the government gifted cap with a shield
after he'd proven his metal in the field
and mclean was never able to duplicate
the process which created it
although repeated attempts would years
later result in the creation of
adamantium the famously strong metal of
which wolverine's skeleton is made
replicas of cap's shield would be
employed for various purposes over the
years but cap always preferred the real
deal
like the super soldier himself it's one
of a kind
shield throwing sense it's a common
misconception that cap's shield must be
equipped with some kind of technology to
make it return to him like a boomerang
but this isn't the case the shield's
ability to absorb and disperse kinetic
energy means that once bounced off an
object it will basically keep bouncing
forever until caught and cap's
understanding of its properties
enable him to predict its flight path
with unerring accuracy
handling it properly is practically a
superpower unto itself to the point
where even the two most accomplished
heroes to take up cap's mantle
sam wilson and bucky barnes both
struggled mightily to learn how to use
it as an offensive weapon
even with extensive training from rogers
however there is one avenger for whom
handling the shield wasn't much of a
problem
clint barton hawkeye perhaps the one
hero whose mastery of physics and
ballistics is on par with caps
leave it to the most underrated avenger
to measure up to cap's exacting
standards
[Music]
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too
[Music]